he news from over the weekend the first
infant is believed to have died from the
corona virus an investigation is now
underway the medical history of the baby
who lived in Chicago was not immediately
released the Commissioner of the Chicago
Department of Public Health dr. Allison
our Witte joins us now
doctor good morning thank you for being
here good morning it seems like we
constantly have to recalibrate our sense
of risk when it comes to the corona
virus at first it was only people in the
upper bounds of age and then it was
middle-aged people as well and now we
have this tragic news about a baby there
in Chicago what more can you tell us
about this infants case so I can tell
you it's very unusual to be seeing a
case like this so obviously we're doing
a thorough investigation working really
with the family our hearts go out to
them the pediatrician the medical
examiner the CDC really wanting to make
sure we're doing confirmatory testing
looking at everything that's underlying
it I spent a lot of time yesterday on
the Facebook live that I do every day
here in Chicago
really putting into the context the risk
that's still where we look across the
world where we look across populations
it's a tragic situation here in Chicago
we're obviously concerned about it but
by and large the main risk does remain
in the older populations the folks with
the underlying medical conditions and
what we don't want to see we did see in
Chicago people bringing in you know
healthy babies to emergency departments
worried about their their health that's
not what we want to see we do want to
make sure that we're keeping this in
perspective even while we're doing the
full investigation that's an important
note and it is a saving grace that's so
far at least it appears as far as does
not affect children and infants and this
is an outlier case but cases are surging
there in Chicago and we know as the
virus makes its remorseless way across
the country
no city no state no County will be
spared so as you see this surge talk
talk to us about the steps Chicago is
taking to bend that curve down
yeah absolutely so we have a very strong
save stay home save lives campaign we've
been tracking every day here we're
continuing we're at about 2,000 cases or
so in Chicago residents about 4,500
across the state and we are working very
hard to do everything we can to keep the
spread down while we prepare the health
care system so we've got the hotels in
place for isolation we doing lots and
our congregate settings working with the
jails working with homeless communities
working with our long-term care
facilities we're working and even
looking at surge capacity in things like
our mccormick place which is our largest
convention center not waiting til the
time where we run out of capacity to try
to build it we've been working at the
health department to distribute hundreds
of thousands of masks just in the last
few weeks gloves all of the other
equipment that we've had on hand here
really put in as part of our planning
for a pandemic but we really do look to
the strategic national stockpile at the
federal level for even more support
around things like ventilators things
like these supplies certainly more needs
still for testing capacity here our
numbers they are but we know yeah mm-hmm
well I just wanted to pick up on that
point about working with the National
stockpile the coordination between state
and and federal and city officials all
across the country it's it seems to be
marred by lapses in communication the
federal government will say they send
something that the state government will
say it hasn't gotten there and then of
course it's got to make its way to
cities like yours can you talk to us
about the communication process and the
coordination going on from where you sit
ah so yeah I can tell you first of all
we have a strong city level emergency
preparedness program that has been
informed over the years with good work
between the states and the federal
government and so we're not waiting for
support
you know from any external source like I
said we're using a lot of the plans and
stockpiles we have here we've put in
requests we certainly there are pieces
certainly we're working closely with the
state and where we see for example the
Army Corps of Engineers is helping to do
the structural build-out at McCormick
Place we've gotten some indication that
we'll receive some supplies which is
really important we're really thankful
for any ventilators in particular that
we're able to beginning because we again
you can't make ventilators out of
nothing you need them here when you need
them but as we're thinking about what
does it look like to staff up some of
these especially the external parasites
really wanting to make sure that this is
part of a national framework for
planning dr. Allison are witty a veteran
of outbreak fights in Liberia and
overseas and now leading the fight on
the front lines in Chicago doctor thank
you very much for being here